[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
FRANK SCHILBACH: All right.
Welcome, everyone, to
lecture 13 of 14.13.
This is my last lecture
on social preferences.
I hope all of you are
doing fine remotely.
Hang in there.
I know this is a
very difficult time.
This lecture is a bit of
a more uplifting lecture
than the previous ones.
While the previous ones have
looked at social preferences,
how we can measure
social preferences,
and how can we perhaps
isolate pure altruism--
do people really want others to
be better for their own sake,
even if nobody knows about
it, either others or whether
there's no feedback--
we sort of found out that like
it seems like what looks a lot
like altruism-- people
are nice to each other--
is not pure altruism
in the sense
that like they really
want others to do well.
Instead, they want to either
look good in front of others,
or they're worried about
reciprocity or sort
of any other negative
feedback from others,
or it might be they might want
to protect their self-image.
They want to look good
in front of themselves
and they try to figure out
ways to deceive themselves
that they're nice.
And given the opportunity
to not be nice,
people actually
seem to be not as
nice as one might think
from pure dictator games
or ultimatum games
that we observe.
This lecture is a bit more
uplifting in the sense
that it talks about field
evidence on social preferences,
and in particular you
can ask the question
about can policies increase
pro-sociology in certain ways.
We're going to talk about
three broad sets of studies.
First, we're going to talk
about social preferences
at the workplace.
I'm going to talk about
the impact of relative pay
on productivity.
We talked about this
last time at the end
of the lecture a
little bit, but I'm
going to just restart from
scratch to sort of explain
that a little bit better.
Then we're going to
talk about the morale
effects of pay inequality.
What happens to
worker inequality
when people are paid unequally,
and is that a good idea?
There's also a very nice
paper in ethnic divisions
and production in firms.
We're going to talk about this
a little bit in recitation.
Number two-- we're going to
talk about whether policies
can induce pro-sociality.
In particular we're
going to focus on mixing.
This is sort of called
the contact hypothesis.
When you mix people from
different backgrounds,
do they become nicer to
each other in various ways?
You'll discuss a very
nice paper by Gautam Rao
when mixing rich and
poor children in school.
And I talk very briefly about
mixing cricket players in India
to reduce tensions across
castes or make people
from different castes perhaps
more prosocial to each other.
And then I'm going to
also briefly mention
a study on mixing roommates
in college by Corno et al.
Finally, we're
going to talk about
whether people
perhaps underestimate
the benefits of prosociality.
In particular, I'm
going to show you
a study on people
undervaluing gratitude.
So when people write
letters of gratitude,
do they understand how
others might react,
and is there perhaps some
evidence that people are not
prosocial enough because they
misunderstand the effects
that that might have on others?
OK, so let me start with social
preferences at the workplace.
So Bandiera et al.
is a very nice study
that looks at the impact of
relative pay on productivity.
This is field evidence from
the fruit farm in the UK.
It's literally field
evidence because it's
from fruit-picking
farms from fruit fields.
The study looks at two
types of payment schemes.
These are piece rates--
workers are paid
per unit of output.
And the second scheme is
relative pay-- workers
are paid relative to others.
We might think that
relative pay is a good way
to incentivize workers
because you want to do better
than your neighbor, and there's
a computation of who does best.
And in principle, it
could be that that,
really, if you only care
about yourself, that really
gets people to work very hard.
Now, what Bandiera
et al. look at
is, how does the
introduction of relative pay
affect workers'
effort and output?
Now, one thing to notice is that
while relative incentives might
be good because you might induce
people to want to be better
than their neighbors
or their co-workers,
there's also a negative
externality of relative pay.
That is the idea that
increasing your own pay
comes at the costs
of others pay.
That is to say, if
there's relative pay
and I work really
hard, I'm paid how
I do relative to my friends or
others that I'm working with.
Well, if I'm working really hard
and do better than my friends,
I'm going to be paid more.
But at the same time, for
any effort that I put in,
my friends are going
to be paid less.
And so workers anticipating
these impacts on others
might reduce their effort
if they care about others.
If I'm really worried about
if there's relative pay
and I work really hard, my
friends are going to look bad.
They're going to be
relatively unproductive,
and I worry that they
might not be paid enough.
Then I might reduce my effort.
And then everybody
might do that,
and then the introduction
of relative pay
or the relative pay
schemes might actually not
be particularly effective or an
effective way of incentivizing
and motivating workers.
So there's sort of this tension
that relative pay in principle
could work quite well.
But if people really
care a lot about others,
then it might not work at all.
It might actually
backfire in some ways.
Notice that it could be either
that people care about others
for their own sake in the
sense that you might care
about them because you want
them to have high earnings,
or you might care
about others' earnings,
not because you actually care
about the outcomes per se,
but rather because
you're worried
about negative repercussions.
If these are your friends
and you work really hard,
well, at nights, your friends
might really not be happy,
and there might be retribution
against you socially
or in some other ways if you
work too hard, if you caused
them their earnings to go down.
OK, so now, what
does this paper do?
It looks at how does
switching to piece rates
affect people's productivity?
So the study has personnel data
from a food farm in the UK.
They measure productivity as a
function of their compensation
scheme.
This is a quasi-field
experiment.
The timeline is as follows.
For the first eight weeks
of the 2002 picking season,
fruit pickers were compensated
on a relative performance
scheme.
So the per fruit piece
rate is decreasing
in average productivity.
So if everybody
works really hard
and I don't, if I'm relatively
bad compared to others,
I get less than others.
This is an incentive,
as I discussed,
to keep the productivity low
if you care about others.
And then in the
next eight weeks,
compensation will switch to
a flat piece rate per fruit.
So that's essentially
just you're
paid by however how
much you produce,
how many kilograms
of fruit you collect.
And the payment is entirely
disjoint or independent of what
other people do.
That's a classic
piece rate payment.
So the externalities
are entirely shut down.
If I work really hard,
I'm going to be paid.
There's no effect whatsoever
on my fellow workers.
The switch was announced on
the day the change took place,
so it came as a
surprise to workers.
So we should not be
worried about sort
of pre-trends or productivity
going up over time anyway.
Now, what the paper finds
is a dramatic increase
in productivity with the
introduction of piece rates.
That is to say what you
see here in the figure
is the average worker
productivity for two
of the fields-- so
that's essentially
like broad, big fields
where people work on,
and I'm showing you
the data for two
of those fields, for which,
essentially, on most days,
there was actually production
workers were picking fruit.
What you see on the left side
of the graph is when people were
working under relative pay,
there you see, essentially,
relatively flat productivity.
People picked about
5 kilograms per hour.
There doesn't seem to be
any trend upwards over time.
So before the new
policy was introduced,
essentially, workers
were producing or picking
their fruit at a relatively
constant rate over time,
about 5 kilograms per hour.
There was no trends, as I said.
Now, you see the vertical
line in the middle.
This is when piece rates
were, in fact, introduced.
So there was no
relative pay anymore,
and now people were
paid by piece rate.
And that increased
productivity by over 50%.
So workers became a lot
more productive after that.
That's true for both
of those fields.
It is not the case that
the average payment
per unit of output per kilogram
of fruit paid was actually
was going up.
So you might say, well, if
the piece rate was actually
higher under the
piece rate payments
on the right side of the
screen, of the graph,
then maybe workers would
just be more productive.
But in fact, if you
look at the piece rate
over time, if anything,
the piece rates
actually went down over time
what the company was paying.
So that is to say,
the introduction
of those piece rates,
the productivity effect
is not explained
by workers being
paid more per unit of output.
Instead it seems
to be really coming
from the different incentives
people workers have
when it comes to how
their productivity affects
their fellow workers
on the field.
Now, you might have two
potential explanations
here for this evidence.
One is social preferences.
So you might work
less to help others
under relative incentives, even
less when your friends benefit.
You have many friends
on a certain field
that work with you.
Well, then you might be
particularly inclined
to not work very hard because
you care a lot more for them.
And this is exactly what
they find in this paper.
These effects are
stronger when there
are more friends on the field
for a particular worker.
Second, however, it's
also like a repeated game.
That is to say, there's
a low effort equilibrium,
where, essentially,
if there relative pay,
we can just all agree
everybody on the field
might agree that not
working particularly hard
is a good idea because
we are essentially
paid relatively anyway.
So if everybody
doubles their effort,
nothing is going to happen
to a worker's compensation.
So you might as well just
decide everybody could just
decide work half
as hard, and you're
going to be paid the same.
And as long as we can
sustain that equilibrium,
that's a good idea.
Of course, in any given
period, any given worker
might have the incentive to
deviate from this equilibrium
because on any given day,
if you work really hard,
you're going to be paid
a lot more for that day.
And so how might we be
able to disentangle that?
Well, what Bandiera et al.
have is they have also
some variation in the types
of fruits that were collected.
What do I mean by that?
Well, if you think
about what you
need to be able to disentangle
these, what you might want
to have is differences in the
observability of effort, right?
So if I can see what
my co-worker does,
I can punish them
very effectively.
I can just know whenever
Frank is working really hard,
my co-workers might
want to punish me.
And then it's very hard
for me to work really hard
because I'm getting
in trouble at nights
after work with my co-workers.
Or in the next day, everybody
might also work really hard,
and I don't want that.
On the other hand, if I can
hide how hard I'm working,
well then, I might
secretly work really hard,
and my co-workers might
not even find out.
So then, if that's the case, in
the repeated game equilibrium
might just not be enforceable,
as in I might just
tell my friends, oh, I
wasn't really working hard.
But in fact, I was.
And they have no way of finding
out because I was unobservable.
If, instead, I really
care about them,
if I'm really interested
in their well-being
overall and their
payment, it doesn't
matter whether my
effort is observable.
Regardless of how
observable my effort is,
I will not work very
hard because not working
hard makes them better off.
So if you just had some
differences in observability
in effort, how hard
people work, we
could just disentangle
these two explanations.
So Bandiera et al. have
this very nice variation.
They have two fruits
there, fruit type
1, which are
strawberries, and they
have fruit of type 2,
which are raspberries.
If you ever have
picked strawberries,
you would know that
strawberries is very easy.
These are essentially
very flat and low fruit
that when somebody
picks strawberries,
it's very easy to see
how fast somebody works,
how much anybody picks and
so on because you can just
see across the entire field.
You can see essentially what
all of your coworkers are doing.
In contrast, if you look at
raspberries, these are bushes.
So you can essentially literally
hide behind the bushes and work
really hard to pick
really hard and fast
without others noticing.
So essentially, productivity
is at least more unobserved
than for strawberries.
Now, what Bandiera
et al. then find,
in fact, is no impact of the
piece rate on fruits of type 2,
which is raspberries.
So that suggests there is no
evidence of pure altruism,
and the effects, perhaps,
could be driven by reciprocity.
This is consistent with
what we had found before.
When you remember the
dictator ultimatum games
that we showed you, it looked a
lot like people are altruistic.
They care about others.
But when you look at
their actual motives,
when you dig a little
deeper, we find out that,
in fact, this is driven by
reciprocity, or by worries
about repeated game effects,
or worries about essentially
just retribution, either on the
field that other people will
work also really hard if
I work really hard right
now, or socially after
work, my coworkers
might be really mean to me.
They might even beat me
up, or they might not
be my friends anymore.
Here is regression tables
that show you this.
The first column,
you see fruit type 2.
Again, these are
the raspberries.
This is when things
are unobserved.
There's no effective
introducing the piece rate.
In contrast, if you look at
column 2, this is fruit type 1.
These are strawberries, and
there's large productivity
effects of strawberries there.
So these results, again,
highlight the importance
of setting the
incentives carefully.
Small details matter,
and you really
want to be very
careful in how you
said relative incentives
that in principle seemed
like a good idea
because they provide
steep incentives to workers, but
in practice might actually not
work particularly well.
OK, so the second paper
we're going to look at
is Breza et al.
These are the morale
effects of pay inequality.
This is a very nice randomized
field experiment in rural India
with low-skill
manufacturing workers.
The question the authors
ask is do workers
care about relative pay?
And perhaps why do we see
so little variation in pay
across settings?
So what we often see in
many companies in India,
but also in other places, also
in certain villages in India,
what we see is wages tend
to be very compressed.
So workers essentially
earn the exact same wage,
regardless of their underlying
productivity, experience,
and so on.
Good and bad
workers tend to earn
exactly the same amount
of money for per day
or per hour and the like.
Economists think
that's inefficient
because if you want
to hire somebody
who's really, really
productive, you
might want to pay them more.
If you want to hire somebody
who is not that productive,
you might want to pay them less.
You might actually want to pay
them less than the prevailing
wage, but you might
not be able to do
so because the norm is that you
have to pay them the prevailing
wage.
And then you might end up
not hiring that person,
and that person might
end up being unemployed,
even though you would be
very happy to pay them
at a lower wage.
This is a really
relevant question.
Sorry, the second
question the authors ask
is what is the notion of the
underlying notion of fairness?
What is fair and
what's not fair?
As in if there is wage
dispersion across workers
within teams or within a certain
firm, under some circumstances
under which that's OK to do?
Are there some
good justification
that workers are OK with, or
is it just always bad to do so?
So can we find some situation
under which it's justified
for workers or not, or is it
just like we cannot pay have
pay inequality under any
circumstances in those kinds
of firms?
This is potentially
quite relevant
for many features
of the labor market.
It might explain
wage compression.
That's what I'm
saying, like wages
tend to be fairly compressed,
even if productivity is fairly
dispersed across workers.
There tends to be
lots of wage rigidity.
Wages tend to not
move very much.
Employers have trouble
adjusting wages,
or they are reluctant to
adjust people's wages much,
in particular when it comes
to like downward rigidity.
We talked about
this a little bit
already when we talked
about reference dependence.
This can help us think about
like sorting of workers
into firms and inequality.
We can think about firm
boundaries in a sense
and say should they
be really large firms
or a number of small firms?
If you think the relative
comparison is across workers
within firms, that would
say, well, we should probably
have a lot of small firms.
And then each of
these small firms
could have different
wages, as opposed
to one large firm where
essentially everybody has to be
paid more or less the same.
And we might think that's
inefficient because as returns
to scale of having a large firm.
Think about it is also
relevant for some HR policies
in terms of how do
you pay workers,
how do you set wages, and so on.
So as motivation in
the study, the authors
ask people the
following questions.
The questions are the following.
This is rural India in Rissa, a
relatively poor area with lots
of small-scale manufacturing.
The question is three
people from a village
get hired to work on a
construction site together.
The prevailing
wage is 250 rupees.
That's the standard
wage in the village.
Each village tends to
have like a prevailing
wage, which is how much
people are paid usually.
The contractor pays
them 250 rupees per day.
How well will they
work together?
And what you see is what
respondents tend to say
is 80% of respondents say people
worked very well together.
20% say as well as usual, and
0% say there will be conflict.
So that's seems like
paying everybody
the same is the socially
acceptable thing to do.
Everybody seems happy with that.
In contrast, if you
ask the following,
which is the contractor
pays them different wages.
If the contractor pays
250 per day, 270 per day,
and 290 per day, how well
will they work together?
And so now, what
you see here is when
there is differences
across pay, 94% of workers
say there will be conflict.
Listen, in this version
of the question,
it doesn't specify whether
that's due with underlying
productivity differences.
So why is it that some workers
are paid different than others?
However, it's very strong
suggestive evidence
that workers might
be really unhappy,
and there will be
conflict across workers
if they're paid different
wages in the same kind of team,
or at least on the
same construction site.
And then, of course,
if you're an employer,
you might be quite worried about
paying people different wages
because of this conflict.
Presumably, workers will not
work or collaborate as well
as they could potentially.
OK, so now the authors set up
a very nice field experiment
that looks like this.
So there's 10 production units
of 3 workers in each factory.
So think of factories like work
sites, factories in quotation
marks because it's
really not just a factory
as you might imagine it.
It's really like a small work
site, an office where people
are working in different areas.
There's 10 units
of 3 workers each,
so it's not a huge office.
Each unit of three workers
produces different products.
So each unit has one product.
For example, unit
1 makes brooms.
Unit 2 makes incense sticks.
Unit 3 makes leaf
plates, and so on.
So each unit has one
item of production.
Now, why are there
different units?
It's essentially
to separate workers
into different lines of work.
So what we're going to
expect is that workers
are going to compare
each other within unit,
but not so much across units
because if I make brooms
and you make incense
sticks, that's
very different
work in some ways.
But if you make the
exact same thing,
the natural comparison
now for workers
to compare yourself
with another worker.
All unit members, so
everybody in a given unit,
makes the exact same product.
So everybody in unit 1, who is
three workers, makes brooms.
Everybody in unit 2 makes
incense sticks, and so on.
Now the key experimental
variation in the experiment
is weight dispersion across
workers within teams.
Finally, there's also-- and I'll
get back to that at the end--
production tasks vary in their
observability of performance.
So that is to say for
some tasks it just
happens to be that
it's much easier
to understand how productive
your co-worker is than
in other tasks.
OK, so now what is the
variation in relative pay.
So here you see people are paid
depending on their worker rank.
There's four different
regimes of pay
in the different
columns, heterogeneous,
compressed L, compressed M,
and compressed H. Workers
are sorted.
So there's a
baseline period where
workers who work for a
few days, and the few days
are used to assess their
baseline productivity.
They're ranked into
three turnstyles,
so there's like the
low productive workers,
median productivity, and
high productivity workers.
They're ranked essentially
based on how well they
did at baseline.
OK, so if you're like
really bad at the start,
you would be a low
productivity worker.
If you're like an
average worker,
you would be median
productivity.
And if you're really like
highly productive worker,
you would be classified as
high productivity workers.
Notice that's always done for
all of the different treatment
groups.
The difference now is across
these different regimes
how workers are paid.
In their heterogeneous
pay essentially, there's
differences in cross
workers in the sense
of like the low productivity
workers are paid low wage,
the median productivity
paid workers
are paid the median weight, and
the high productivity workers
are paid the high wage.
As you might expect, that's,
sort of, the natural thing
to do in terms if wanted
more productivity, the most
productive workers you're
going to pay the most.
Notice that these wage
differences are modest.
Even like the
difference between W
high and W low are like
only about like up to 10%.
So really these are
not huge differences.
It's not that the other guy if
you are like low productivity
worker if you get W low,
it's not the other guy
gets like twice as much.
It really is like modestly
more, but it is more money
that they get.
Now then if you look at the
other three regimes, compressed
L, compressed M, and compressed
H, low productivity-- so
in compressed L, everybody gets
to low wage, in compressed M,
everybody gets the minimum
wage, and in compressed H,
everybody gets the high wage.
And now the study
now lets the authors
compare the different
columns for holding exactly
constant baseline
productivity and wage levels.
That is to say, for instance, we
can compare the heterogeneous--
the low productivity
workers that
happen to be randomized
into like the heterogeneous
treatment, they receive
W low or compare them
with like low productivity
workers at baseline who
happen to be randomized
into a compressed L.
So I should have
said more clearly
people are randomized into
any of these four groups,
and then depending on what
your baseline productivity is
you get the wages as I
show here in the table.
So for example, if you are
like a low productivity worker,
you might be randomized into the
heterogeneous treatment group.
You might receive
W low, or you might
be randomized into the low--
compressed, low treatment
where you also receive W low.
Notice that in both
cases, that worker
is a low productivity worker.
In both cases, the
worker receives W low.
However, what's different here
now is that his co-worker--
his or her--
in this case,
these are all men--
co-workers are receiving
either the same, which
is in compressed L, or
they receive higher wages
in the heterogeneous
weight treatment, right.
So now we can look
at workers who
have the exact same baseline
productivity on average
at least and have the exact same
weight, but what's being varied
is like how much other
workers are earning.
We can do this for low
productivity workers.
We can also do it for
median productivity workers
or also for high
productivity workers.
I skip the median
productivity worker,
but that's exactly the same.
For high productivity
workers, we
can look at the workers
who had been randomized
into the heterogeneous treatment
group or heterogeneous worker
group--
sorry, heterogeneous
wage group where
the worker gets a
WH but everybody
else gets like a
lower wage, or we
can compare that to
compressed age where everybody
gets WH in that group.
OK, so now what do you
what do the authors find?
Let's start with
the low productivity
workers at baseline.
Remember the collinear
comparison here
is between pay disparity-- this
is a heterogeneous group-- pay
disparity and
compressed L, which
is like the group where
everybody is paid the same.
Now what the authors find--
and you see this in the graph
fairly nicely, which is
like the productivity--
these are like the red
line and the blue line--
the productivity
on the left side-
this is before the treatment
starts for about over 10 days--
the productivity looks
pretty much the same.
But then when you go to the
right side of the graph,
not immediately but after a
few days they seem to be a gap
or a gap emerges between the red
line and the blue line, which
is exactly the gap as you would
expect if the disparity makes
workers less productive, which
is to say the workers who
receive a low wage but
others in that group
are receiving higher wages
are becoming less productive
compared to workers that receive
a low wage where others have
the exact same productivity.
And you see this also in
the regression tables,
you see about a 22%
reduction in mean output
and a 9% reduction in earnings,
which are pretty large effects.
So these are like
large effects compared
to like other interventions
that people have tried.
Interesting, you
see a little bit
like while the treatment effect
when you look at the graph
initially looks not particularly
large, if anything it might not
even be there often like a few
days, that treatment effect
increases over time.
It becomes larger
so over time people
become less and less productive
compared to the compressed wage
treatment.
Interestingly, we
find-- the authors
find similar effects for high
ranked, high productivity
workers.
So notice that these
are not workers
who either who are high
productivity workers
to receive the same wage in
the pay disparity treatment
and the compressed H treatment
that have the same wage.
In one case, they are
paid exactly the same.
In the other case,
they're paid more
compared to their coworkers.
And what happens what
seems to be the case
is that the compressed high
paid workers are, in fact, more
productive compared to others.
You might have expected in some
ways like if one guy gets paid
high payment but
then others get paid
less, that makes the high
pay worker more productive,
because maybe he feels
good about himself
that he's a high paid workers.
And maybe he feels he can
prove himself or the like,
but instead what seems to
be the case the group that
works in his team that does not
work well together or they just
becomes uncomfortable to work
with somebody else who is like
really mad at you for
earning more than they do.
And so now the high pay workers
in the compressed treatment,
in fact, earn more
or produce more
than the high paid workers in
the pay disparity treatment.
So that is to say
the pay disparity,
pay inequality does
not only reduce
worker's productivity
for the low pay workers,
so not only the people--
the workers who are earning less
compared to their co-workers,
and that's in some
sense to be expected.
You might just be mad at
everybody else or other people
in your group are earning more.
Then you might be unhappy
and mad about that
and just then produce less.
Instead it seems to be the
case even the high productivity
workers, the workers who earn
more than others in their group
are producing less compared
to the control group where
everybody earns the same.
So what did we learn from that?
Well, pay disparity lowers
worker performance for all team
members, and so the
interpretation of that
is that pay disparity undermines
workers ability to cooperate
in their own self-interest.
The paper has some
additional evidence
with some cooperative
tasks where
essentially workers are worse
at cooperating with each other.
It seems to really be
that workers are not
happy to work in the
same place with somebody
else who earns less.
Importantly, the
perceived justification
is essential in
mediating these effects.
That is to say I told you
previously that for some task
it was easier to see who was
more productive than others,
especially at baseline
just because in the task
the difference is across highly
and less highly productive.
Or high and low productivity
workers was just wider,
and it's just easy to see that
Frank is really bad at this
and somebody else
is really good.
And for some task, it's
really easy to see that,
for others not.
So if it's really
easy-- if there's
a perceived justification
for workers,
if workers, sort of,
thought, OK, it's
really easy to see who is
more productive than others,
the effects are much
weaker than when there
is no receive justification.
That is to say workers
themselves are saying,
like, if I'm saying,
look, there's
this other worker who
is really productive
and if I'm sort of
saying, hey, look,
this is really
obvious that they're
more productive than
I am, it's only fair
that they're earning
more, then the affects
are much damage-- then there's
much less than an effect that's
accepted, and there's much
less of a productivity
effect, if any, if
there's pay inequality.
However, if it seems to
be the case that they're,
kind of, like producing
the same thing,
if we like similarly
producing the same thing
and we're equally good at it
or approximately equally good
and one person is paid more
than I am for no good reason,
so it appears that workers are
really not happy about that,
then work performance, in
particular output falls.
So what are the implications?
Well, this evidence suggests
that weight compression
may be more likely in some
settings than in others, right.
That's to say like if
it's easy to justify,
if the production function or
like the production process is
such that all aspects of the
production and the output
or the performance are easy,
measurable, and observable
for workers, then
workers might say
it's OK if some workers are
earning more than others.
However, if that's not the case,
if there's a bunch of stuff
in the work process that's
really not observed--
maybe it's verbal or maybe just
really hard to justify or hard
to sort of assess in
some tangible way--
then workers might
be really unhappy
and that might lead
to weight compression,
because the employer
might anticipate that.
So overall, this, sort of, says
that like relative comparisons
matter quite a bit.
Fairness matters quite
a bit, and what's
really key for an
employer and anybody who
sets incentives is to take
into account these fairness
considerations, and one wants to
really understand what is fair
and what is not.
And upsetting workers by
violating these fairness
considerations or norms might
be really, really costly
for an employer.
So the good news here is that if
one understands that well, one
can really sort of produce
increased productivity quite
a bit, and in some cases weight
inequalities actually fine.
One just has to be careful in
figuring out when exactly is
that the case, OK.
As I said, there's
a very nice paper
by Jonas Hjort on
ethnic divisions
and production in firms.
You're going to talk
about that in recitation.
OK, the second part
of this lecture
we'll talk about policies
to increase pro-sociality.
And so the first
of these papers is
very nice recent paper by Gautam
Rao that looks at the question
are social
preferences malleable.
Like, what are the origins
of social preferences?
Why is it that some people
appear nicer than others?
And then once we
understand that,
perhaps, we can also understand
what policies, if anything,
can affect social preferences.
The main question
that this paper asks
is how does being mixed
with poor students in school
affect the social
preferences of rich students.
Now in a lot of the,
kind of, policies
where poor students are
mixed with rich students,
you might ask the
question, how does
it affect the poor student.
If a poor student
for whatever reason
would not be able to afford like
a rich school or rich student's
school and you,
sort of, allow them
by giving them scholarships
or other policies,
often the question
that people ask
is like what are the
benefits of doing that.
Is the poor student
doing better in school,
or do they have different types
of friends, different networks,
and does it lead to better
jobs and so on and so forth?
This question, this paper
ask a different question.
It asks the question about what
is the effect of rich students
if they randomly
or quasi randomly
are exposed to being in class
with additional or some more
poor students.
The paper exploits
a policy change
that introduced an admissions
quota of 20% for poor students
in primary schools in Delhi.
In Delhi, these are
rich primary schools.
The paper looks at two
sources of variation.
There's variation
across classrooms
that allows the author to
look at the overall effects.
So you can look at, like,
within schools there's
going to be treated
and controlled cohorts,
because the policy was
introduced at some point.
So for some students,
they enjoyed
the benefits of being in
class with poor students
or the costs.
We'll see about that.
And for other schools, they're
already too far advanced.
They were like
essentially before the--
they went to school before
the policy was enacted,
and therefore they
were not exposed
to having poor
students in school.
For these treated
schools there is
essentially variation
within school across cohorts
that we can look at.
Second within cohorts.
We can look at treated
and control schools.
So some schools were getting
additional poor kids and others
did not.
I'll tell you about
this in a second.
And then there's variation
within classrooms
to allow us to look at the
role of personal interactions.
There are, sort of,
idiosyncratic assignments
to study groups,
so some students
happen to be in study
groups with a poor kid,
and others were not.
Now what does this
study measure.
The study measures three
broad set of outcomes.
It measures pro-social
behavior and generosity.
This is very much what we
have already looked at.
In particular, it looks at
dictator games and volunteering
for charities at school.
The paper has a very nice
mix of laboratory outcomes,
sort of, measured
in the field, which
is, sort of, the dictator game
that you're all familiar with.
And field outcomes,
were just, sort of,
trying to collect
real world outcomes
in the sense of like
things that are, perhaps,
somewhat less contrived from the
perspective of kids in school.
And what's very nice
about the study is
that it seems to be that the
results are very much aligned
between, sort of, these live
outcomes, the dictator game
type outcomes, and
the field outcomes,
which is volunteering for
charity at school in this case.
Second, the author
looks at discrimination
in social interactions.
In particular, he does it
all sports contests and looks
at teammates selection
among these students
and then willingness to attend
play dates with poor students.
Finally, the author also
looks at academic outcomes,
in particular test scores
and disciplinary infractions.
Now why might one want to
look at academic outcomes,
and why we're interested
in social preferences,
there's several
reasons for that.
In particular, an
important reason
here is that if you're
against this type of policy,
I might, sort of, show you
that, oh, adding poor children
might affect the social
preference of rich children
and so on in various ways.
Maybe discretization goes
down, but perhaps it's
the case that all comes at the
cost of academic performance,
right.
If you're trying to, sort
of, implement this policy
and persuade policymakers, maybe
teachers or parents of like,
OK, let's have more poor
students in your school.
Well, parents might,
sort of, be OK fine.
There's going to be like some
change in social preferences,
some change in
discrimination, but really
what we care about is test
scores or discipline at school,
and these poor
kids might not be--
might be worse in
terms of test scores,
and they might have
negative peer effects
in terms of test scores
but also in terms
of disciplinary infractions.
And, sort of, as
a policy question,
then it's really
important to understand
if there are some
benefits in terms
of poor sociology or
reduced discrimination,
do these benefits
come at the cost
of reduced academic performance?
So now what is, in fact,
the policy innovation
in Delhi in 2007.
There was a 20% admissions quota
in private schools introduced
for poor students in some
of these private schools.
There's a household income
cutoff of $2,000 per year.
So these are not,
sort of, the poorest
of the pole of the
students who are qualified.
Schools which received
subsidized land
from the government
were essentially
included in this policy change.
That's over 90% of
elite private schools.
So think of these
These are really, sort of,
like very rich kids or parents
of these kids.
There's no fees
for the poor kids,
because they would not be able
to afford these fees anyway.
There was importantly
also no tracking.
So it wasn't that high ability
or high performance kids
would do very well
where they like
tracked into the high tracks
and the good tracks verses
lower tracks.
Instead everybody
was mixed together,
poor and rich, high performing,
low performing students.
And the poor kids were
selected using lotteries,
which in principle also allows
the author or others to look
at the effective on those
poor kids, the students who
are selected versus not.
To be clear this is not
the subject of this paper.
Just to give you a sense of the
magnitude of like the mixing,
you see is that the average
beneficiary was a, sort of,
at the 25th percentile of the
income distribution in Delhi,
and wealthy students are
very much on the right tail--
sorry on the right tail of
the distribution, something
like the 90th percentile,
95th, which is about--
the US equivalent of that would
be about $200,000 per year.
The average beneficiary
had like the US equivalent
income of like $23,000.
Again, these are not
the poorest of the pole
but relatively poor as about
like an order of magnitude
poorer than the average
person in the actual school.
Now this policy then
induced large variation
across classrooms.
If you look at poor students
in the fraction of the numbers
of poor students in
by grade in 2011,
I told you the policy
innovation was in 2007.
So if you look at 2011--
that's four years later--
anybody who is in
grade four in 2011
has essentially no poor
student in that class
in those rich schools.
So for students who were in 2011
in grade four, five, or six.
That policy came too late.
They did not have
any poor classmates.
In contrast, if you look
at the lower grades,
grades 3, 2, 1, and 0,
which essentially preschool
or minus 1, which
is preschool grades,
there's lots of
additional poor students
now in those rich schools.
Now again, there's
variation within schools
and across schools.
The variation within schools
is across classrooms.
That's, kind of, what
I'm showing you here.
But it's also a
variation across schools.
So just to be
clear, the variation
within schools across classrooms
is like in the treated schools
there's some classes like
the fourth grade have
like essentially zero poor
kids in their classes,
and the third
grade, in contrast,
have lots of poor
kids in the classroom.
They can do that comparison
across classrooms
within school.
In addition, has also
variation across schools.
There is, in particular,
there's treatment schools, which
comply in 2007 as
they were supposed to,
but then there's also
delayed treatment schools,
which complied in 2008.
So the jump shifted
by one cohort.
So the cohort, the jump
that I showed you here,
this is for the treatment
schools that complied
or this for everybody
that complied in 2007.
The delayed one
complied a year later,
so you'll see them essentially,
somewhat later increasing--
or one year later
exactly increasing
the fraction of poor
kids in their classroom.
And then there is
the control schools
that were not subject to the
policy, at least until 2013.
So they had received--
they had received land from
federal government or private
foundations.
So essentially there
was no treatment.
That is all students are rich
in these types of classes.
So that is-- the land
receiving is essentially just--
that was like a fairly
arbitrary rule in some ways.
So that, sort of, leads to at
least quasi random variation.
And some schools received the
treatment, and others did not.
Now let me show
you some outcomes.
So one outcome is our friend
the dictator game which you have
seen quite a bit and played
already as well is students are
allowed with 10 rupees,
which is not very much--
that's about like $0.15--
and they choose to share--
notice that these are
pretty young kids,
so 10 rupees is quite a
bit of money for them.
They choose to share an amount
as before between 0 and 10.
And Gautam sets this up
such that students could--
it was not just about
the money, but they also
can exchange the money for candy
later, add 1 rupee per piece.
So that was a pretty good deal.
Then the dictator games for
the order was randomized.
The kids would play two games.
Again, so all rich
kids would do that.
They play first game one where
the recipient is a poor student
in a school for poor children.
And in game 2,
it's a rich student
in a private control school.
Notice it's a control
school to be clear,
so it's not a kid
that they might know.
So the kids are chosen
such that the kids were
given the names and the
photographs of the school shown
to the subject, to the kids.
So you could sort of see--
and this is verified
in the briefing
by the author-- is that
the children understand
very well who is a rich
kid and who's a poor kid,
but these are not kids that
they would actually know.
And something that's a
less interesting question
if you have gone to school
with somebody for a long time,
you might have seen them
around in your school yard,
you might be nicer to
them or less nice to them.
That's not what the
study is looking at.
The study is looking at
other kids in other schools
that look rich or look
poor both in terms
of the way they're
dressed and so on,
but in particular the way
their school looks like.
So essentially these are--
now we're looking at
social preferences
towards other people, people
that these kids don't know.
OK, so now what do we see.
So this is a
generosity to the pole.
So like this is essentially the
results from game number one.
Again, remember these are all
rich kids who are giving now
to poor kids, and the question
now is being exposed to
or does being exposed to poor
children for several years,
does that affect giving
in the form of dictator
games towards poor
children to start with.
And we're going to talk about
rich students after that.
So here you see the generosity
to the poor in control schools.
You see this is the percent
to the poor recipient.
It's remarkably similar to
what we've seen previously,
which is about 20% to 30%.
About 25% is given to the
pole kid in the control
groups in the control schools.
This fraction seems to trend
up a little bit over time,
but it's also quite constant
over time across grades.
You see here by grades
two, three, four, and five
on the x-axis.
On the y-axis, it's the percent
given to the poor recipients.
Now adding the
treatment schools,
now we find that
for two grades--
for grade two and grade
three, remember the graph
that I showed you here.
You see that in grades
three, two, one,
and so on, these
are the kids who
are exposed to the poor
children in class in contrast
to grades four and five
that have not been exposed
to poor kids in their class.
So what this graph shows
is that exactly the grades
three and two that
have been exposed--
in the treatment
groups that have
been exposed to poor
classmates, these
are exactly the students, the
grades where giving is higher
towards the poor compared
to the control groups
but also compared to the
older cohorts four and five,
the grade four and five.
When you look at
grades four and five,
they see essentially no
difference between treatment
and control schools.
So they seem to be very similar.
In contrast, if you
look at grades three
and through where the
treatment kids are exposed
to the treatment by having the
poor kids in their classrooms,
these are exactly the years
where giving goes up and goes
up by quite a bit.
While the average was, as
I said before, about 25%,
that goes up to about 35%.
So that's a pretty
large relative increase.
Now in addition, as
I told you, there
are also delayed treatment
groups, treatment schools.
For those schools, if
you were in grade three,
it was also too late for you,
because the treatment was
introduced only a year later.
So if you were in
grade three, you
did not have any poor
kids in your school.
Now if you look at
the yellow line here,
the yellow line looks very
much like the green line.
That is for the delay
treatment schools,
there's no impact either.
They look very much like the
control group of schools,
as you would expect.
However, in the delayed
treatment schools
in grade number two,
that's the grade where
the students are exposed--
the rich students are exposed
to the poor kids using
the essentially similar effects
to the treatment schools,
as you expect.
So that's fairly
compelling evidence
that really the differences that
you see across these schools
are driven by the
treatment that was--
the timing of the treatment
as opposed to other potential
effects due to like selection
or maybe these schools
are different and so on.
We see essentially
no differences
in grades four and five for any
of the treatment and control
schools.
You also see no
difference in grades three
for the delayed
treatment schools
compared to the control group.
In contrast, we see
clear differences
in grades two for the delay
in the treatment school as
compared to the control schools.
We also see a clear difference
for the treatment schools
compared to both the control
schools and the delayed
treatment schools as well.
So that's fairly
compelling evidence
that game or play,
dictator games
changes when
students are exposed
for quite a long time to
poor kids in their classroom.
OK so now in
addition, we will have
variation within classroom.
So what I show you here,
this is all variation
across classrooms.
That is to say, if you have
a poor kid in your classroom,
you will behave differently, or
that will change your attitude
toward your giving
and dictator games
towards the poor or
other poor children.
Now, in addition,
the author also
has evidence of variation
within classroom.
Now, he lets you think
about for a second,
why is it important to also
have variation within classroom?
Isn't the evidence that we have
here already compelling enough?
Why do we need more?
And you can think
about it for a second.
The reason for that is that the
diff-in-diff, the difference
in differences comparing
essentially across classrooms,
identifies the overall
effective having
poor classmates in class.
That might be the result
of personal interactions.
But it might also be the
result of the teacher.
The curriculum might change.
Your parents might change in
some ways in just telling you,
look.
There's these poor
kids in your class.
The teachers might
tell everybody, oh, you
need to be nice to poor kids.
The curriculum might change.
It might sort of
include things that
tell you to be nice to
poor kids and so on.
You might be sort of exposed
to just different types
of material.
So really, given the
evidence that we have here,
when you just compare
across classrooms,
you cannot disentangle whether
this is driven from being
personally exposed in terms of
interacting with poor children
personally by just talking
to them in certain ways,
or being exposed to them, or
learning about them and so on.
So you cannot disentangle
personal interactions from
teacher or curriculum
changes that are essentially
at the classroom level.
So in addition,
then, Gautam also
has a within-classroom
strategy that
exploits the assignments
of study groups.
What is that doing
is essentially,
it isolates the role of
direct personal interactions
and is not subject
to sorting concerns.
Another concern might be
that you might sort of say,
oh, well, in this
school, they're
having poor kids
that are allowed
into this private school.
I'm going to send my
kids to somebody else.
So that's also an issue perhaps
potentially in the evidence
that I showed you before
across classrooms.
The within-classroom
strategy is now
looking at everybody
who is in that classroom
and looking at some kids
were just randomly assigned
to be in study groups with
poor kids, and others were not.
And that sort of allowed
us to disentangle
or allows us to
isolate the effect
of personal interactions.
So one hour a day, kids
were working in small groups
of 2 to 4 students.
Remember, this was for a
very long period of time.
So it's one hour per
day, but it was also
for quite a bit of time.
It's not just doing
that once or twice.
It's more an extended
period of time.
And crucially, some schools
use the alphabetic order
of first names to
assign study groups.
So that's essentially
exogenous variation
in personal interactions.
Other schools frequently
shuffled the groups and only--
which essentially sort of--
everybody was equally
exposed to those kinds of--
to different students.
So you are sometimes in study
groups with rich students
only and sometimes with
poor students only.
In the first group where the
alphabetic order was used,
you were either sort
of in the study group
where you happened to be
next to somebody who's
a poor kid because they
happened to be next to you
in the alphabet, or you're
not, and that stayed the same.
Now, what does this
let us look at?
Essentially, the alphabetical
order predicts study partners.
So now you might say people
with different names might also
be different.
So it could just be
that like my name--
because my name
is different, I'm
more likely to be next in the
alphabet to a poor student.
For example, if I'm
a rich kid and there
are some names that are more
similar to poor kids' names,
it could be that my parents
are particularly tolerant.
They also gave me a name that
sounds like a poor person.
And therefore, I'm more
likely to be in a study group
with the poor kids.
And that's not the impact
of being in the study group
or rather sort of selection.
It could be that
names are different
or people with different
names are different.
So that's why having this
control group is really nice.
So what we can look
at now is to say,
you can look at kids that have
names adjacent to rich students
and kids that have names
adjacent to poor students.
So if you look at
the left side, this
is essentially
looking at students
that have their names
adjacent to rich students only
or students that have
names adjacent to also
some poor students.
When you look at that, where the
alphabetic order was not used,
the outcome here is
what's your share
of having poor study partners?
And so there,
essentially, there's
no difference, as it should be,
because the alphabetic order
was not used.
There was a shuffling
around the kids
all the time, so
it didn't really
matter what your alphabet was.
It didn't really matter.
But crucially, we can
still look at the alphabet.
We can look at kids
that have names
where, Jason, in the
alphabet, there's
only rich kids, rich students.
Or they can look
at kids that have
names where, adjacent
to the alphabets,
there are poor students.
And, here you see on the
left side of the graph,
you see essentially no
difference across these groups.
So they were equally likely to
have a poor kid in their study
group.
In contrast, on the
right side of the graph,
you see the alphabetic order
was used to assign study groups.
So if you had a name adjacent to
a poor student in the alphabet,
you're very, very likely to
have a poor kid assigned to you
or be in your study group.
Not always because sometimes,
these are groups of three.
So sometimes, you
were lucky or unlucky
depending on how you view it.
The group was just above you
or below you in the alphabet.
But most of the
time, if you have
a name adjacent to a poor
student, that student
or any student would
be in your study group.
If you didn't have a
name adjacent to you or f
you only had rich
students adjacent to you,
there's still a
chance that you have
a poor student in
your study group
because it could be just like
not the person next to you
but another person further down
is, in fact, a poor student.
You end up in that
group with that student.
Remember, these are
groups of 2 to 4 students.
So it could just be that you're
in a group of 3 to 4 students,
and not the person adjacent to
you but the person after that
ends up in your study group.
So you're still likely to have--
you have still like about
like a 40% chance of having
a poor kid in your study group.
But there's a huge
difference between the two
types of groups.
The name adjacent
to the study group
has a huge fraction,
about 90%, versus 40%.
So crucially, now,
we can compare
for both types of
schools, for the schools
on the right-hand side where,
essentially, the names are very
predictive of having a poor
kid in your study group,
versus on the left-hand
side where the names are not
predicative at all whether you
have a poor kid in your study
group.
And so we can--
that way, we can keep selection
the same, the types of name
are the same.
We are isolating
the impact of having
a poor kid in your study group.
Now, what does the author find?
He finds that-- this is
what we showed you before,
which is in the control
group, we had about,
in the dictator game,
these kids gave about 27%.
Having a poor kid
in your classroom.
That's the evidence that
I already showed you.
The treatment effect is
about 12 percentage points.
That's fairly large.
That's almost like
a 50% increase.
A little bit less than that.
So that's a huge increase.
And then in addition,
when you look
at kids that have a
poor study partner,
notice that these are things
not necessarily additive,
but if you have a poor
study partner versus not,
there's an effective about
7.5 percentage points.
That's a pretty large effect.
So both of these
things seem to matter.
Personal interactions seem
to be quite important.
But in addition,
there seem to be also
some additional
effects perhaps coming
from the classroom level.
You might-- so there's
two types of effects
that are possible here.
Some types of effects could
be from the teacher, parents,
curriculum, et cetera.
Might be different.
Or other things
could be just like,
even if you don't have a
poor kid in your study group,
you might still play with
them or be friends with them
or just seeing them around in
the classroom might affect you.
But crucially, the
personal interactions
seem to be very
important as well.
Now, one question you might
ask is, well, so far, I
showed you generosity
towards poor children.
So that was game number 1.
We looked at what happens
in the dictator games
when a rich kid
plays with a poor kid
and the rich kids become
nicer towards the poor kids.
Now, how about generosity
towards other wealthy children?
Well, it turns out that
that increases as well.
So it's a smaller effect size,
but it's still substantial,
and, in fact,
statistically significant.
So why might that be?
You might sort of ask,
well, what's going on here?
So here's the evidence.
You sort of see the change in
giving to rich participants.
This is sort of
like a distribution.
You see this is the share
giving to the rich participant.
It seems to be what happens--
these are essentially
the fraction
of students in the different
treatment versus control
who give 0%, 10%,
20%, 30%, 40%, 50%.
And what you see-- there is
about a 10 percentage points
decrease in the fraction
who give 0% and about
an 8-something percentage
points increase
in the fraction who give 50%.
So it seems to be that there's
quite a few students who
move from 0%.
About 10% of them
move from 0% to 50%.
And 50-50 is kind of like
the equal allocation.
So rich kids also becoming
nicer towards rich kids
in these dictator games.
So what's going on here?
There's different
potential explanations.
Perhaps the most plausible
explanation-- the study
has some evidence on that.
At the end of the day, it's
hard to sort of entirely
nail this or rule out all
other potential explanation,
but it's quite plausible
that what's happening here
is that inequity,
students, when you're
exposed to poor children, you
are essentially a bit more
averse to inequality or inequity
across people, even in things,
in fairly trivial things
such as dictator games.
Now, I told you before,
that's a little bit funny
because dictator games
obviously are very narrowly
framing people and looking
at essentially very
narrow outcomes.
If we have, like, a 50/50
outcome in the dictator game,
that doesn't mean that
our life is the same.
You might be still
much richer than I am.
So having sort of equal
outcomes in the dictator,
the 50-50 allocation
in the dictator game,
might be narrowly framed, in
that particular game, fair.
But of course, it's not fair
in the grand scheme of things.
But what seems to be
the case is that--
and there's some other
evidence in the paper
that you can read
if you would like.
It seems to be the case
that rich children become
more averse to unequal outcomes
in the world in general
because they essentially
see these poor kids who
are very smart and
are disadvantaged
in terms of various
ways from having
lower wealth of their parents.
The rich kids become sort of
more adverse against that,
and that translates
even into dictator games
with other rich kids in a
very sort of minor thing
in the world and in
these dictator games,
again, even though these
dictator games actually
don't change very much.
But they really seem to
be averse to inequality
of these outcomes and move
them from the 10-0 allocation
to 50-50, even with
these rich kids.
OK.
So that was evidence
on social preferences
as measured by dictator games.
But people also had some
evidence on discrimination.
In particular, a small field
experiment on team selection.
So what does this study do?
So its subjects
are, again, students
from two elite private schools.
So now, it's like two of these
selected schools are selected.
One is a treatment school.
One is a control group.
And in addition, Gautam
invited athletic poor students
from a public school.
Importantly, he said,
athletic students-- these
are students who are better
at sports than the rich kids.
You might think the
poorer kids are better
at sports than the rich kids
anyway, which is probably true.
But now, these are particularly
athletic students on purpose
who are invited to attend
a sports event as well.
Now, students in this
experiment, in this game,
must choose teammates
to run a relay race.
Now, when you're a rich kid
who is thinking about who
should be in my
team, you can either
choose a rich kid who is
kind of like similar to you
in social ways, or you
can choose a poor kid
who you don't know very much.
You might actually not
like the poor kids.
But the poor kid is a lot
better in the running,
so it might be much
better for you.
You might be much more
likely to win in the game
because now your partner in
the relay race is much faster.
So it's a very nice
trade-off between ability--
choosing the fast runner
versus social similarity.
And now, what
Gautam then is doing
is like, if you sort of
choose the rich kid, that's
then a measure of discrimination
because essentially, you're
choosing a worse
runner in favor of
or because you want
more social similarity.
You don't want to hang
out with a poor kid.
Instead, you choose
the rich kid,
which reduces your
chances in the race
but increases your time
spent with the rich kids
compared to poor kids.
Let me tell you a little bit
more detail of the experiment.
Stage 1 is randomization.
So the people were randomized
to sessions with varying stakes.
There's 50 rupees, 20 rupees,
500 rupees per student
for the winning team.
This is a lot of money compared
to students usual pocket money,
right?
So they would get something
like $10 or 500 rupees
is like one month's
of pocket money.
So that's really high
stakes for these kids.
The price is
varied, essentially,
because it lets us price out.
It gives us a price
of discrimination.
Lets us understand how much
are students willing to give up
in order to not have to--
or in order to be able to
socialize with the rich kids
compared to the poor kid.
There was a brief mixing
to start with to judge
socioeconomic status.
So the kids were allowed
to mingle a little bit.
That would allow them to
fairly easily understand
who was a poor kid
and who's a rich kid.
OK.
Stage number 2 was ability
revelation and team selection.
So you could essentially
observe a two-person race.
Usually, it's one poor
and one rich students.
Neither is from the old school.
So these are not
students that you
would know from school anyway.
But the uniforms make
the school identifiable.
You kind of know who is the
rich kid and who's the poor kid.
Now, then you can pick
which of these two runners
you want to have
as your partners.
So that is to say you
see them run one by one.
It's very easy to see
who's faster and who's not.
And so again,
discrimination here
is interpreted as
picking the slow runner.
So if you pick
the slower runner,
then it must be because
you like something
some other characteristics
about that person more.
The obvious
characteristic here is
that it's most likely going
to be that kid is rich.
OK.
Then stages 3 and 4 are
the choice implementation
relay race.
So students are
randomly picked to have
their choices implemented.
So some of those choices--
this is, again, the
strategy method.
Some of these choices were
actually randomly implemented.
So there's plausible
deniability for the students
in the sense of you could
just happen to be randomized
or you happen to pick some
students versus another.
It could just be
by chance that you
are with one student
versus another.
So you could-- your freedom
to choose essentially
provide you cover.
Sometimes, as we
discussed before,
the computer is choosing, so
you always have an excuse.
So it's intended to reveal
student's true preferences as
opposed to perhaps
what they think
that their friends want them
to choose or the other runners.
Then the relay races
were actually held
and prizes were
distributed as promised.
Number 4, crucially, there
was a social interaction.
So if you picked your
teammate, you actually
had to spend two hours of
playing with a teammate.
Board games, sports,
playgrounds, and so on.
Importantly, this
was preannounce.
So now, again, as I said before,
when picking your partner,
you have the choice
between either picking
the fast, poor kid,
which will really
increase your
probability of winning,
or the rich kid,
who is kind of slow
and will reduce your
probability of winning.
But if you pick that
poor kid or the rich kid,
you have to actually spend
two hours with that teammate
playing board games, sports,
playground, and so on,
and you might not want to
do that with a poor kid.
OK.
So now, first, what is the
demand for discrimination?
You can look at this graph.
It shows very nicely for
the different prices.
As I said, 500 rupees for
winning the race, 200 rupees,
or 500 rupees.
If you look at 500
rupees, this is again
one months of pocket money.
There's no difference
between treated and untreated
classrooms.
That is to say--
so there's 10% of
people are, as you
want, discriminating the poor.
So this is less than 10%
is about 7%, 8% of students
pick the rich kids, even in
the really, really high stakes
race.
That is to say, when the
stakes are 500 rupees,
there are, like,
about 6%, 7%, 8%
of students who still
pick the rich kids,
and they sort of
take into account
the chance that that
might lose them the race.
But they don't have to spend
two hours with a poor kid then
socializing.
Now, when you look at the
lower prices, the fraction,
as you expect-- this
is the red line.
Sorry, this is the green
line, the upper line.
The fraction who
choose the rich kids,
the fraction who
were discriminating
against the poor,
increases as you expect.
So now, it becomes cheaper.
The race is only 200
rupees or 50 rupees.
You might be more inclined to
pick the rich kid because you
know the value of
socializing stays the same,
but the costs of
picking the rich kid,
the cost of losing
the race, potentially
at least is reduced.
If you look at 50
rupees, the price
of 50 rupees for the game,
for the relay race, that's
about almost 40% of students
now pick the rich kid,
even though that might
lose them the race.
And now, crucially, in
red, the dashed line
below, you can see the
treated classrooms.
And what he finds is
that for 500 rupees, when
the stakes are really, really
high, there's no effect.
Essentially, it
doesn't really matter
whether you are in a treated
or a not treated classroom,
in part perhaps because there's
not much room for going lower
than that.
So essentially, there's
no effect on there
because you know the stakes
are really, really high anyway.
There's not much discrimination.
And having had a treated--
having had a poor
kid in your classroom
doesn't really change that.
But then, very clearly, for 250
rupees and 50 rupees, the lower
stakes, there's a
clear difference
between the green
and the red lines.
That is to say, there's
a lot less discrimination
towards the poor kids.
Poor kids are a lot
more likely to be
chosen when a student
has-- in treated classrooms
when somebody had a poor
kid, another poor kid
in that classroom
for several years.
So that's to say there's--
being exposed to
these poor children
reduces discrimination among
the poor among the rich students
subsequently.
This is sort of the same graph
that I showed you before.
Again, that's sort of consistent
with what we have before.
It gets a little messier
than we had seen previously.
But similarly, even
within classrooms,
if you look at grades
2 and 3 versus 4 and 5,
the effects seem to
be concentrated more
pronounced in grades 2 and 3.
Now, finally, as I said, we look
at test scores and discipline.
So arguably, there are
some positive effects
on social preferences.
And as I said before, the
policy question now is,
does that come at the cost
of academic achievement
in some ways?
So is it that the rich
kid now, by being exposed
to the poor kids, may be
somewhat nicer and more
friendly and less
discriminating against the poor?
That's all and good.
But is it the case now
that test scores go down?
So Gautam finds no effect on
aggregate test score index
or zero effect in
Hindi and math.
There's a little bit of a
reduction in English scores
of 0.9 standard deviations.
That's marginally significant.
That's suggestive but not
perhaps particularly large.
So these effects are
not particularly large.
And in particular, in aggregate,
so if you agree to everything
together, there don't seem to
be any significant effects.
So perhaps the English scores
are suggestive but sort of not
particularly large.
There's some mild
effect on discipline.
Interestingly, there's
an increase in swearing.
You think that's good or bad.
You can think about that.
But there seems to be a little
bit of an effect in terms
of language uses.
There's no effect on violent
and disruptive behavior,
which you might think is a lot
more damaging, potentially.
OK.
So just summarizing,
what does the paper find?
Well, having poor classmates
makes wealthy students
more prosocial and generous.
They're more likely to
volunteer for charities.
I didn't show you that evidence,
but that's another piece
of evidence that he finds.
They're more likely to give
in money in dictator games
to give them more higher
fractions of their shares
in dictator games.
They also choose more
equitable outcomes
in sort of disinterested
third party games
where essentially, you choose
between two other students
and their allocation.
So it's not just
that they're more
likely to be willing to give
up money that others get,
but also, they're more likely
to choose equal allocations
in third party games
and disinterested games.
Again, I didn't show
you that evidence.
But it seems to be that
what's increasing here
is sort of like
inequality aversion
in these sort of disinterested
dictator or the types of games,
where essentially, these
students, by being exposed
to poor kids, are now more
averse against unequal outcomes
in these types of games.
Second, there is
less discrimination
and more higher willingness
to socialize with the poor.
They're more likely to
choose poor teammates
in sports contests.
They're also more willing
to attend playdates
with poor children.
Again, I didn't show
you that evidence.
And then there's some
small, negative effect
on academic outcomes that I
think are mostly negligible.
Now, there's other work
on the contact hypothesis
that I showed you.
So the contact-- what is
the contact hypothesis?
The contact hypothesis goes
back to at least Allport
in 1954, which is the idea
that interpersonal contacts
reduces prejudice until
certain conditions.
And not just prejudice,
but also changes
attitudes and social
preferences potentially.
So Matt Lowe, who was a
PhD student here at MIT,
has a very nice paper that
looks at cricket tournaments
and asks the question whether
cricket leagues in India
can increase cross-class
interaction in pro-sociology.
So what he does is he
randomizes, essentially,
cricket leagues and
teams in cricket leagues
where people across
different castes
are now more or less likely
to play with each other,
both in terms of-- he
varies or there's variation
in the study within teams.
So are you more or
less likely to have
a-- or some people are
more or less likely to have
a lower or higher caste.
So a person from a different
cast in their team.
And he has variation in what
he calls adversarial contact,
which is they're more or less
likely to be exposed to players
from other teams in
higher or different castes
from themselves.
So if you're on the
team and have a person
from a different caste on your
team, you're on the same team.
You share the same objective,
and you want to win together.
So now, having somebody
from a different caste
or just somebody who's different
in various ways in your team
might make you like them better.
You might be sort of
more positive about them.
You might be sort of more
likely to talk to them.
You might learn about them.
You might sort of see
some sides in them
that you hadn't seen before.
So you might be more like they
sort of empathize and look
at sort of nice
characteristic of them
and sort of update them
positively about people
from other tasks, and that
changes your attitudes
towards them in general.
If, however, you play against
somebody from different castes,
you might, actually-- that
might, actually, if anything,
backfire, because you really
don't like your opponents.
You might see them
very negatively.
You might be aggressive
towards them.
You might be unfriendly
You might sort of
not like that they
win against you or the like.
So I'll just add, these
adversarial interactions
might actually
backfire in the sense
that they might not
foster integration
but actually sort of
make things worse.
So Matt runs this experiment
and finds evidence of increased
cross-caste interactions.
So people are more likely
to be friends, more likely
to hang out with others.
They also are more generous
in dictator and other types
of games.
They also are more
likely to engage in trade
or in economic exchange.
So what Matt does is he
sort of randomizes gloves.
It's like left gloves
and right gloves.
And he does the
same for flip-flops.
Left flip-flops and
right flip-flops.
And people are more likely
to trade with somebody
from another caste if they
ever been on the same team
with people from other castes.
If they have a higher
fraction of people
on their team of people
from other castes,
they're more likely to engage
in all these behaviors.
They're more likely to have
cross-class interaction.
More likely to be prosocial.
More likely to engage
in economic exchange
with people from other castes.
So that's all true for
collaborative contact.
That is to say, that's contact
with people on the same team.
In contrast, for adversarial
interactions, when people
are on the opposite team, having
more people from other castes
or being exposed to more
people from other castes
does not have these
positive effects
and, for some of these outcomes,
have even negative effects.
So if anything, that
sort of backfires.
It doesn't-- just-- a
mere exposure to others,
if you are sort of in an
adversarial contact situation,
does not really foster
prosociology or any of these
types of integration.
If anything, it backfires.
Now, why is that important?
If you think about
like, for example,
attitudes towards
immigrants, it really
matters hugely what types of
contacts people are exposed to.
If people have worked together
in the same team, if they have,
perhaps, team pay, if they were
to work towards the same goal,
really, it seems this
evidence suggests
can foster prosociology
and so on and so forth
that leads to integration,
reduce discrimination,
and so on and so forth.
So it's sort of the
incentives are aligned
or if you could sort of set up
incentives that are aligned,
people might become
nicer to each other
and interactions
might be fostered.
In contrast, if
contact is adversarial,
if you're worried that
immigrants are taking away
your jobs, being
exposed to immigrants
might just do the opposite.
So you might see a
lot of immigrants.
But in a way, if
you feel like you're
in computation with them,
if they're adversarial,
if they're sort of your
enemies in some ways
or your opponents in some
computation for a job,
being exposed to them might
things, in fact, if anything,
worse.
Finally, there's another
piece of very nice evidence
by Corno et al.
This paper is
considering the impact
of random interracial
interactions
among college roommates in
South Africa on stereotypes,
attitudes, and performance.
So what they look
at, essentially,
is roommates of
different race reduces--
so these are black
and white students--
reduces white students
stereotypes towards blacks
and increases
interracial friendships.
It also improves grades and
lowers dropouts among blacks.
So there's sort of a
number of positive effects
of a very simple
policy of increasing
contacts among roommates.
And again, if you think
about this evidence,
it seems to suggest that perhaps
that's kind of like if you have
a roommate that you're
going to live with for quite
a while, that feels a lot
like collaborative contact
in the sense of, like,
you're sort of stuck
with that roommate
for quite a while,
so you might as well sort
make the best out of it,
even if you initially
don't like that person
and you have the same objectives
of being happy together, living
together.
And that really seems
to foster and have
some positive benefits.
So taking together,
that sort of says, so A,
the contact hypothesis
seems to be broadly right.
Contact to people who
are different from you
might make you more tolerant
or more prosocial towards them.
There might be more
sort of integration
of different groups.
But what really seems
to matter quite a bit
is the type of contact
that people are exposed to.
So finally and
relatively quickly,
I'll tell you a little bit about
whether people underestimate
the benefits of prosociology.
I should mention
that problem set
3 question 2 is, in fact, trying
to ask you to do something
related to that.
So you might want to actually
do the problems at first
before you finish this lecture.
At least sort of-- sorry,
not the entire problem
set, but question 2
of problems set 3.
That will not take you
very long to do so,
and it's more like
a fun exercise
that I thought would be
nice for you to engage in.
But anyway, this is a very
nice paper by Kumar and Epley.
That's a typo here.
It should say Kumar and Epley.
And the officer is asked
the question about,
do we have correct beliefs
about the impacts of generosity?
And so what's the
underlying reason here is,
well, many prosocial acts
require estimating the impacts
on the recipient.
If you give money to
somebody in Africa,
if you help anybody and people
in need, if you donate money
in general, if you write
letters of gratitude
or if you do random
acts of kindness,
it requires some sort
of estimation of,
how is the other person going
to feel if they receive--
if they are on the receiving
end of this prosocial act?
Now, what Epley
and Kumar argue is
people are subject to
egocentric bias, which
may lead them to
systematically underestimate
the positive impact
of prosociology.
In this case, gratitude letters.
And so why is that?
Well, it's because predicting
others mental states is
difficult. It's
really hard for people
to understand how another
person might feel.
Usually, people would sort
think about themselves
and sort think about how would I
feel, and what would things be,
and how are things like.
And it's very hard to understand
how others might react to you.
It sort of requires
perspective taking,
and that's sometimes
tricky for people to do.
So this is again a
very nice experiment
by Kumar and Nicholas Epley.
Not Nicholas last name,
but Nicholas Epley.
And they test whether people
misunderstand the consequences
of showing appreciation.
And so what are
these experiments?
There's a series of
experiments that look at this.
What do they look like?
But what they do
is they ask people,
MBA students or
subjects in experiments,
to pick a prosocial act.
That's writing a gratitude
letter, for example.
And then ask how the giver and
the recipient will be affected.
In some cases, it's only the
recipient, and in some cases,
also the giver.
Then they perform the
prosocial act by, for example,
writing a letter of gratitude.
And then assess how the
giver under recipients
were actually affected
by doing that.
And then you can compare
that to item number 2.
To the estimation x ante.
Now, what do they find?
They find clear evidence
that when you look at,
like, in particular, when
you look at the giver--
so these graphs all show kind
of the predicted ratings.
The ratings is between 0 and
10 about what's the experience?
How happy is the other person?
What is the surprise about
receiving this letter
of gratitude in this example?
So people are more
surprised than predicted.
They are also more
surprised about the content
than predicted.
They're also-- the
recipients mood
is actually better
than predicted.
And the awkwardness is
also better than predicted.
So when you ask people to
write letters of gratitude,
people tend to
say, oh, you know,
it's going to be tedious
to do, and the other person
might feel it's awkward.
And what am I going to say?
And is it going to be weird
when I'm going to say?
Is the person-- don't
they know already
anyway that I'm really
appreciate of that person?
And so on.
So people come up with all sorts
of reasons why they might not
want to do that.
If you sort of introspect and
ask yourself how many letters
of gratitude have you written
in the last year, that doesn't--
few people actually
do that in practice.
And perhaps some of these
reasons like the perceived
awkwardness or perhaps
sort of the underestimation
of the recipient's mood
might contribute to that.
Now, if you also think
for a little bit,
like, how would one actually
feel to receive these letters,
it's pretty obvious
once you think about it
that most people are actually
quite happy about receiving
such letters.
It's kind of nice if
somebody tells you, look.
You did something really
nice for me some time
a long time ago, and this
helped me a lot in my career
in whatever way, or getting
into school, into college
or whatever it might be.
It's really nice to sort
of hear from somebody
that you did something
nice in their life
that people are
quite happy about.
Now, what's sort of some
evidence, some summary of that?
Well, so we tend to
systematically underestimate
other's appreciated and
expressions of gratitude.
That's also true for some
other types of effect.
That tends to be also true
for random acts of kindness.
People tend to be surprisingly
more happy about those
compared to predicted.
It's also true-- so
Epley and Schroeder
argue for social connections.
So people also
underestimate on average
how they themselves
and others feel
when starting conversations.
So what this experiment does
is this gets people to-- it
randomized people to start
conversations during commuting
on buses or trains.
And once people start
doing that-- again,
before, when you ask them, like,
how is the other person going
to feel, how are
you going to feel,
and so on, people will say,
well, it's going to be awkward.
And what are we
going to talk about?
And is the other
person even interested?
And so on.
But when you actually
do that, people
seem to be quite happy to
have started conversations
and making human connection.
To be clear, not
everybody is happy.
Some people might
be also grumpy.
But the vast majority, at
least in these types of study,
seem to be quite
happy about initiating
social contact,
about expressions,
letters of gratitude, or things
like random acts of kindness.
It's really nice
if somebody happens
to be something to do
something nice towards you.
Could be like a random person
who you've never seen before
and you never see again.
Just some random person on the
street is really nice to you.
That might make your day.
It could be also
somebody who quite well,
and he's a good
friend, and who just
wants to do something
nice for you
for no good, apparent reasons.
So one caveat to these
kinds of experiments
is these are very much
like one-short, short
interreactions.
These are one-time interactions,
and then the effects
are measured.
So there are some
questions about,
do these effects persist
for repeat interactions?
That is to say, like, maybe
if you do that once, people
are quite happy.
But when you try it more often,
these effects tend to go away.
So there's a bit of a question
kind of like, how persistent,
how important are
these in practice
if you do that more often in
particular in the long run?
And then another
important question
here is then the
question about always
under-investing in prosociology
in terms of our behavior.
So lots of people who
tend to be quite selfish
and do good things for
themselves and not so much
others--
presumably, they do
that because they
want to make themselves happy.
Presumably, people who do
nice things towards others
to some degree do
that because they want
to make the other person happy.
In part perhaps
because of social image
and self-image concerns.
But one important hypothesis
that Epley and others raises
the question of, like, well, are
we underestimating how good it
might not only make
others feel but also
ourselves feel from being nice?
That is to say, perhaps, one
easy way of making ourselves
happy is not just by being
selfish and maximizing whatever
outcomes but really, being
nice towards others, in part
perhaps because it just
makes us happy to see
when others are happy.
Perhaps it makes us
happy because others
will be then nicer to us.
And there's a
question about, can we
make others and
ourselves happier
by being more prosocial,
perhaps because we
underestimate to start with
what these effects might be?
I don't think there's
that much evidence
on this specific question,
but I'd love to learn more.
And when you think
about your own life,
you might want to
experiment for a while
and seeing trying
to be nice or trying
to engage in random acts of
kindness, letters of gratitude
and so on, that might be
a nice habit to acquire.
And you might see it may or
might not make you happier.
Surely, it will make the other
person on the receiving end
happier.
OK.
So let me sort of
summarize what we learned
or what we studied on
social preferences.
So first, others' outcomes and
utility matter for people's
choices quite a bit.
So in various situations,
essentially, people
are willing to give to
others, and they're influenced
by others in their choices.
Now, upon closer
look, there's not
much evidence of pure altruism.
Rarely does it seem that
people just do stuff for others
just for the sake of
others doing well.
That is to say, if people
get the chance of hiding
they're not so nice
actions, they will often
take advantage of that.
The motivation there
often is instead
motivation to give to
others or be nice to others
to be prosocial is often saving
face in front of others--
this is social image--
or themselves,
which is self-image.
So here-- and because of that,
situational circumstances
matter greatly.
Societal norms are really
important to consider.
So when you think
about incentives
or any sort of types of
structures and organizations,
how might you--
incentives, or how might be sort
of a structure certain groups
of people working together,
understanding these norms
and circumstances is key
for fostering prosociology.
If you want people to
be nice to each other,
you have to set it up in a
way that it's maybe observable
what people do.
It's encouraged.
There's opportunities for
reciprocity, and so on.
So a lot of the
design of society,
of a firm, of a group
that you work in
or a team that you work
in really seems to matter.
So on the one hand,
as I said before,
it's a little bit
disappointing that there's not
much pure altruism.
But on the other hand,
if you sort of understand
the motivations for
people being to engage
in acts that are
good for others,
you can sort of design
incentives and structures
that people work in accordingly,
which will then create people
being friendly and
cooperative to each other.
Second, I showed you
that social preferences
matter at workplaces.
Relative pay can depress
incentives to work.
This is evidenced by Bandiera.
The fruit pickers
that I showed you.
Pay inequality can lower
performance via reduced morale.
So in particular,
if pay inequality
is seemingly unjustified, that's
really bad for worker morale
and might lower our
worker outputs and sort
of attendance and so on.
Third, social preferences appear
to be malleable and shaped
by external factors.
In particular, there's
evidence in favor
of the contact hypothesis.
Being exposed to others from
different backgrounds really
seems to make us more
tolerant and more
understanding, more prosocial
towards these other groups.
But also more prosocial
perhaps in general, which
is the evidence by Gautam Rao.
And then finally,
there's some evidence
that biased beliefs may lower
prosociology in the sense
that people might under-invest
potentially in how nice
they are to others perhaps
because they misunderstand
what the effective of
engaging on such a prosocial
act might have on others.
And so potentially correcting
these beliefs or experimenting
might sort of increase
prosociology, at least
in some settings.
Now, what's coming next?
What are the next lectures?
Lecture number 14 is
about limited attention.
15 is about projection
and attribution bias.
This is the idea
that people have
trouble projecting
how they might
feel on different
states of the world.
That is the idea if
you're really hungry,
it's really hard to project how
you might feel when you're not
hungry and vise versa.
We're going to look at that.
In lecture 16 and 17, we'll
look more specifically
about beliefs and learning.
We talked a little
bit about beliefs
already in various ways.
But now, we're going
to talk specifically
about biases in
beliefs and learning,
as in people sub-optimally
learning perhaps because
of computational issues
in the sense that it's
really hard to learn
in some settings,
in part because of
motivated beliefs.
People might drive utility
from their beliefs.
As in, for example,
I might want to think
that I'm a good-looking,
smart, and a good teacher.
And if I get feedback
on one way or the other,
I might react to positive
feedback a lot more.
I might sort of update
positively if somebody says,
Frank, you're really smart.
I might sort of
update positively
because I feel
really good about it.
If somebody says instead,
Frank, you're not so smart,
I might mostly
ignore that feedback
because it might make me
feel bad about myself.
So that's all for now.
Thank you so much.